I'm 36 a witch it's not what I was
hoping for was actually hoping for a
seat that's not gonna happen
that's gonna go down today poor woman
bras aren't necessary evil if you need
the support they're there to support you
but I think that a hard day at work you
take it off and it's the best feeling in
the world
that's that's not that's not gonna be
the most universal bra would say is like
you know just like a nice Demi cup broad
but you have to be where sister sizes
because a 34b yeah okay what's that old
34 B's sister is 32 C because 34 is like
your band one without other exactly boom
holler at your boy I can feel like a bit
of pressure on the back but it actually
kind of makes me want to stand up
straight more I understand why Brava and
it happened in the sixties because this
is a whole restrictive thing right here
supports a bra provides comfort and hold
you in when you're working out so if
you're bouncing around at the gym doing
stuff your breasts aren't gonna be all
over the place and it's gonna hold you
in place they're gonna be good to go
there's so much to remember and
incorporating something like this into
your daily routine it might be a
challenge ladies my hat goes off to you
and my bra goes off they don't show up
on the shoot oh we did you seatbelts and
browser just a terrible mix it's hot in
these cuffs dog like I don't have any
breasts in these cups and it's still
warm I could definitely feel the strap
one of the straps like really really
bearing down into my shoulder but I know
that would leave a mark like this I got
red marks all on my undercarriage and
stuff here take this
I don't think I could make it out of the
house in a timely French watch these
later I think I'm gonna call my mom I
have a question for you I was wondering
how do you wash a broth all right it's
just got done with a run and if you'd
like to know what it feels like to wear
a sports bra it's like wearing boxer
briefs made of wet scuba suit material I
do gotta say expanding in the star Venus
the worst thing of wearing a bra for a
week was wearing a bra for a week this
is your whole day with the strapless bra
this movement is your whole day the
worst part about wearing a bra for a
week was actually getting the thing on I
caught people staring at my chest and it
made me feel like a deer in the
headlights I got some eyes on me we're
in the bra was very hot now sports bras
are much more comfortable I don't think
it's possible to relax with a bra
because you lean back and it's like
there it is and so you're messing around
with it the marks on the skin man like
on my rib cage you know my back I just
it was digging in best part of wearing a
bra for a week is coming home after a
long day at work and just taking off the
bra it's such a road leaving feeling
look ladies you know the saying that you
know you couldn't walk a mile in my
shoes well I could not last a week in
your bra maybe get caught up right in
there yeah that is not a good feeling